And then I did like a bunch of like crazy like uh
uh a lot of butt
ones stairs and all that.
All the butts just things that like really just help you go for
a while. You know what I mean? What? That's just things that
things that just really just keep you going for like a minute.
You know what I mean? Just keep just keep your heart rate going
up and
survive under pressure. Yeah. No, I I understand that. I understand
that. That's a good thing. Um that's a good thing. I actually
do a lot of cardio as well, so I can last. Uh really Yeah. I
don't know if you knew this, but I think I do like an hour a
day of cardio, so I can uh my my heart I mean a lot of uh heavy
heart rate. I can I can exist for a good minute.
Um he's got good endurance. Yeah, it's pretty it's pretty good.
Do you guys know like any cardio that you can do with two people?
Oh, so times times that.